ok ich teste die schlechteste pizza ich
habe jetzt einen kanal eine serie in dem
ich essen mit verschiedenen youtuber
teste da würde ich übrigens demnächst
auch mal neue folgen machen hat
vorschläge für kandidaten mit dem ich
mal seinen assen testen soll statt sonne
die kommentare aber heute testen was
anderes und zwar werde ich heute die
schlechteste pizza in meiner stadt
testen und das ist besonders schlimm
weil meine stadt ist relativ groß also
ich wohne in köln wie max tauch und
könnte eine million einwohner und
dementsprechend auch sehr sehr viele
leben die pizza anbieten von der laden
wir euch heute eine pizza bestellen
werde ist wirklich er mit der
schlechtesten bewertung in der ganzen
stadt
ich bin noch mal hab ich habe keine
ahnung was heute im laufe des videos
passieren wird wirklich die pizza
positiv überraschen ist ihm noch
schlechter vorgestellt habe werde ich
eine lebensmittelvergiftung bekommen
keine ahnung wie wir uns das vorüber und
bestellen so leute dann darf ich euch
jetzt mit freude das restaurant
vorstellen bei dem ich jetzt gleich mal
eine pizza bestellen werde und danach
vermutlich sterben werde das restaurant
pizza steinofen
für mich sieht es aus wenn jemand so in
zwei minuten in paint gemacht und pizza
steinhofen weil geschätzt dass der platz
um die besten lebensmittel aus italien
geht hat sage und schreibe 158
bewertungen und daraus einen stern einen
aus 58 bewertung ein stern
das ist nicht so dass irgend jemand sich
gebracht hat der typ hat nicht nur einen
witz gedacht bei der bestellung ich geb
dir mal ein sterbender 58 leute haben
uns bewertet und sind bei einem stern
rausgekommen einen durchschnitt gewesen
aber leute wir können jetzt nicht
einfach da so rein stürzen und die
irgendwelche barbaren einfaches essen
bestellen nein wir müssen uns erst mal
die ganze sache schmackhaft machen mit
ein paar bewertung beschreibt nicht zu
empfehlen absoluter halte will ich hier
gelandet neckar schreibt wie eine
tiefkühlpizza nie wieder
franken eva schreiben leider echt
schlecht und bestellen kann die perfekt
heute ich bin jetzt an dem punkt
angekommen wo ich auch wirklich absolut
lust habt mir hier eine pizza zu
bestellen 9 euro mindestbestellwert in
einer geburt also zehn euro mal für
selbst vergiftet rausgegeben jetzt
natürlich die frage welche pilze
beständig ich glaube ich bestelle die
ich sonst auch öfter schon bestellt habe
und dann bei anderen restaurants und
nicht ein bisschen vergleichen kann die
gut die wirklich ist und das ist in
diesem fall eine pizza jetzt immer noch
2 euro 20 bis zumindest bestellt wird
ich könnte jetzt noch so pizzabrötchen
oder so was bestellt aber ganz ehrlich
ich bin froh wenn ich nur eine pizza
[Musik]
anton kramer okay leute das hier ist die
ein stern pizza riecht nach stimmen
machen die frau mehrere aber hat das
französische pendant akademische pizza
bestellen aber es ist französische recht
französisch später das schwimmbad man
muss aber auch beachten
ich weiß mir rüber kommt aber wie
schlecht der druck auf dem karton es
sieht so aus als sei er schon ein paar
jährchen älter der katze ganz kurz bevor
ich die tester das video ist nicht dafür
da diesen laden zu helfen also ich
möchte ich das irgendwie da hingeht und
die hätten oder so oft letzten endes hat
es auch leute die irgendwie ihr geld
verdienen wollen ist es einfach zufällig
so dass dass die verwendeten pizza in
köln ist es egal was sie bestellen ok
den bereit
[Gelächter]
[Applaus]
der käse sieht seltsam aus irgendwie
bisschen mysteriös ist und jetzt auch
nicht so schlecht aussieht erstmal nicht
giftig aus muss man sagen die leute wie
sie ihre kleine die ist richtig weit
weit die ober- oder man sieht das ist
echt komisch ich frage mich wer ist die
kundschaft von so einem laden also ganz
ehrlich ich würde mein bauchgefühl sagt
mir man muss eigentlich extra jetzt bei
den datenbeständen nicht gar nicht so
viele leute bestellen den mega trucks
bewertung niebel über wenig kundschaft
über
jetzt folge mitleid gehabt natürlich
haben die volle wenig kundschaft über
lieferheld aber ich habe es vermisst mit
dem ok also wir sehen schon die pizza
hälfte auf jeden fall erkläre ich mir
das jetzt man muss aber sagen ganz kurz
zuvor noch loslegen der schenken sich
eigentlich ganz normal ausbauen was man
eigentlich positiv vermerken dass die
pilze sind keine dosen pizza gesehen
relativ franchise aus eigentlich sehen
aus wie so hat frisch drauf gelegt
weißt du was ich erwartet hätte einfach
nur tief gekippt ist aber ich auch dass
auf jeden fall eine frisch gemacht ist
okay jetzt weiß ich teste die
schlechteste pizza in der ganzen stadt
wird nicht gespart
ich darf der blick die man macht wenn
die gitter gesteckt ist dieses problem
ist ich hab mich jetzt darauf
eingestellt dass das die schlechteste
pizza sein muss dass alles irgendwie
seltsam schmeckt aber ich muss sagen die
tomatensoße ist gut
die tomaten isst kann man wirklich die
meisten zu machen
aber die ist wirklich lecker sind ein
bisschen gummiartig das merkt man ja
sicher dass die knusprig oder sonst was
schmeckt auch ein bisschen so ein
bisschen boomjahr dem beispiel
war der rahmen ist kann man den rand zu
bieten hat einfach kommen gut aber was
man noch sagen dass lieferzeit ging
eigentlich folgte und liefert so gut
also die pizza war
ich glaube die zehn nach 1 bestell jetzt
20 vor zwei es geht eigentlich klar
märz wieder an stücke nicht mehr und
wird auf einen wert
das ist eine gute zahl bis zu sagen dass
keiner gerne besser ich sage gehört das
hat es irgendwas stellt mal darauf ein
dass die schlechteste pizza in der stadt
testet er brauche immer ihr seid geht
mit der einstellung hin dass wir die
schlichteste pizza testet glaub mir
alles wird selbst abspecken
[Musik]
irgendwas an dieser pizza ist auf jeden
fall so mega gummiartig nicht weiß was
es ist ein meister der teig ist das kann
nicht sein
wenn sogar der hand so ist ist ja eine
steinharte aber vielleicht verstehen
muss man einfach nicht warm wenn die
pizza backen
also man muss sagen der käse ist
wirklich mysteriös jeder war darüber so
zeigt das mal ich finde es erkennt man
auf den ersten blick das ist ein
bisschen seltsam axis weiß was meine es
ist aber nicht so schlimm
der schlimmste käse das hatte ich auch
schon mal hat man vergessen den versuch
analogkäse verwendet was käse der kein
käse ist wahr machen unsere leute ist es
jetzt zeit also ist zeit für meine
bewertung und ich muss sagen diese pizza
hut nicht überrascht sie hat mich
wirklich überrascht warum weil ich
gedacht hatte mit einem stern bewertung
dass das schlechteste was man bekommen
kann überhaupt ich habe ich mir so etwas
gerechnet wie er kommt eine
tiefkühlpizza oder so kürzer kommt gar
nicht aber dann bin ich positiv
überrascht zum beispiel davon lassen
also frische pilze darauf sind die
tomatensoße ist gut der schinken ist die
konsistenz der pizza ist nicht gut habt
ihr gesehen dieses mega blick ich
persönlich habe nicht so ein
riesenproblem mitzubringen blitzen ich
weiß dass ich bei dir die hand geklappt
aber es ist einfach ein qualitätsmerkmal
wünschen sich okay so sehe ich das auch
aber ich wollte eigentlich um das nicht
prinzipiell beweglicher weil sie wissen
wollen erst preis leistungs weil es gut
ich hab jetzt halt die pizza sechs euro
80 gekostet was man sagen das ist
überhaupt nicht mehr das recht normal
große pizza hut ein bisschen größere
also preis leistung ist okay würde ich
sagen man wird auf jeden fall sagt ohne
sich um ihn zu vergiften dann kommen wir
jetzt zu meiner endbewertung leute ich
gebe dieser pizza von fünf sternen
insgesamt 3 es gibt ja ich muss wirklich
sagen diese pizzeria ich bin echt
überrascht hat diese bewertung nicht
verdient ein stern ist unfair das ist
echt und viermal die pizza das ist eine
drei sterne pizza was würde
vom look ja auch so was zwischen zwei
und drei sternen weinheim
ich fühle mich wissen schlecht weil ich
jetzt ein video oder so also den gewinn
wenn ich entscheiden könnte welche
werden dieses restaurant hat von der
pizza würde ich mich einstellen geben
mal ganz ehrlich welches restaurant
einen stern verdient nicht vorbei okay
leute kurzerhand nach drei noch mal ich
hab weil ich einfach dumm bin von hunger
hat und die katze pizza gegessen und ich
muss doch ich muss doch zwei einheit
geben auch mit sympathie bonus mehr als
zweieinhalb sind echt nicht dass er mein
test von den schlechtesten pizza in köln
mcgarry war